IRFAN BAQUI: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to "Apigee Up Close."
My name is Irfan Baqui.
I'm a custom engineer
with Google Cloud,
helping our customers make
better architectural decisions
as well as better API
management decisions,
and today we'll be talking about
insights-driven API programs.
And the objective is just
to share our philosophy
on analytics and monitoring
and relate it to your business.
I'll give you a lot of examples
of how our customers are
leveraging insights to make
their businesses better,
to make the API programs
better, and then toward the end
I'll take you
through a demo that
will showcase everything that we
talk about in the presentation.
But the central idea really
is that a business needs
real-time insights on multiple
different levels to be agile,
and I'll show you today on how
you can get those insights.
I'm sure you're
familiar with Apigee.
It sits in the middle
of all of your services
in your applications, and all
of the data that goes through
between your applications
and your services--
it goes through Apigee.
And the good thing about
this is that Apigee-- it has
a lot of data passing
through, and it
can give you the right insights
on how your services are doing,
both on a business level as
well as on an operational level.
And when we are talking
about this data,
the one thing to keep in mind
is that the data is usually
associated with a
particular entity.
So on the left you
have the customer.
On the right you have
your back end systems,
and that's how the data
flows, left to right
and right to left.
And it is associated with
a customer, an application,
and a developer, and it
accesses particular APIs,
which are part of different
products of yours.
And in turn, those APIs--
in Apigee, then, they interact
with specific back end systems.
So all of these
insights are very
specific to the
particular entity,
thus they can give
you a good glean
on how your business and
your API program is doing.
So now let me tell you about
our philosophy behind insights.
We look at insights in a
lot of different levels,
and the first level is
just your core business.
Everything starts at
your core business KPIs.
What is your business strategy,
and what are the metrics
that you need to
track to achieve it?
And you would want
to track that,
and you can do it in
Apigee in very close
to a real-time basis, be it your
revenue, or your subscriptions,
or the health of your
marketing campaigns.
You can track all of
those insights in Apigee.
The second one is the insights
about your API program.
How is your API program doing?
How many developers are signing
up in a particular week?
The different applications
the developers are making--
how are they
consuming your APIs?
What are the experiences that
the end users are getting?
So all of those insights you can
get from a good API management
platform like Apigee.
The next one is at
a product level,
so within your API
program you would
be exposing a lot of different
APIs bundled together
as a product that represent
a cohesive functionality.
And you want to see how those
products are being consumed
by your customers, and you want
to see how one product relates
to the other and figure out
how you can make them better,
invest the right resources
to make them better.
And lastly, the
operational level analytics
for your operations teams, and
these have to be real-time.
So if there is something wrong
in your APIs on Apigee or even
in your back end
systems, you want
to get alerted in real time with
the right amount of information
that will help you solve
that particular error,
and you'd be able to
get that with Apigee.
So now let me talk about
some of our customers that
are using Apigee Analytics on
all of these different levels.
So one of the customers I want
to talk about is T-Mobile.
T-Mobile is one of the largest
telecommunications providers
in the United States, and they
are reinventing themselves
as a technology company.
They are modernizing
their entire stack,
and they're using
Apigee as the API layer
on top of everything to manage
the APIs, and govern them,
and all of that.
So one of their key business
metrics that they track
are subscriptions.
And they're able to
get business insights
into how the API program is
supporting that key business
strategy and how many
subscriptions they're driving.
So thinking about T-Mobile,
it has a good online presence.
It also has a very
good brick-and-mortar,
concrete, offline presence.
It has thousands of
stores across the US,
but at the same time,
they're also selling
through big-box retailers.
And they would want to find
out what kinds of demographics
resonate better in one
channel versus the other.
The people who would buy
T-Mobile subscriptions
in the retailer Target may
be of a different demographic
than folks that buy
the subscriptions
at Best Buy or Walmart.
And you want to make sure that
you are appealing to them,
you're providing the right kind
of product to each one of them.
And that's possible by
gaining the right insights
from that demographic.
The other customer I want to
talk about is Domino's Pizza.
Now, you would think that
Domino's is in the pizza
delivery business,
but actually they
are in a B2B business, servicing
their franchise owners,
and these franchisees--
they have their own IT systems.
Then Domino's needs a way to
integrate into their delivery
systems, and their payment
systems, and all of that,
and they are able to
do that with Apigee.
But at the same time, to
stay competitive and lure
the franchise owners in staying
with Domino's and opening up
even more franchises,
they need to provide them
with relevant
insights on how they
can make their programs better.
And with a platform like
Apigee, as all of the data
is flowing through,
they would be
able to give them insights on
what does the best delivery
experience look like?
Who are the target
demographics, what
are they interested in
across different geographies,
and what are the success
factors and success criterias
that the franchise owners
can implement to make
their businesses better?
The other customer I want to
talk to you about is Walgreens,
and Walgreens is really
a classic example
of a customer that has developed
a robust developer ecosystem.
Walgreens-- if you're aware, it
is one of the largest pharmacy
chains in the United States.
Back in 2008, they started
to experience a drop
in their photo business because
folks weren't using film
rolls anymore, and they were
using their smartphones instead
to take pictures.
And then it was really
important for them
to understand the
end user behaviors
and figure out how to
get those users back.
Well, they found out that
they were taking pictures
with their smartphones,
but they still
wanted to get those
pictures printed.
So they created some native
applications, mobile as well as
desktop, to
basically enable them
to get those photos printed
at a nearby Walgreens.
And that restored some
of their business,
but they said,
hey, I think there
is some more potential here.
And they started to get insights
into what kinds of pictures
were these customers printing.
And they found out that
a lot of this traffic
was coming from other photo
services that would enhance
their customers' photos.
For example, at
Halloween time you
would upload a picture
to one of these services
and decorate it with
pumpkins or something.
So they were experiencing a lot
of traffic from such services.
They said, all right, how
about I expose my photo prints
API to these different
applications and services
and incentivize them
to route their traffic
to get the photos printed
at a nearby Walgreens store?
So they did that, and
their ecosystem exploded.
There were actually net new
apps that the developers
were making just to
tap into the incentives
that Walgreens would give
them to direct traffic
to their stores.
So that was very successful.
And then they replicated
that model to other products
as well.
So now they have a plethora
of products ranging
from prescription refills,
and rewards programs, and home
delivery services that
are basically just
APIs that they're exposing.
And they're being integrated
in the developer's applications
and thereby giving more business
and traffic to Walgreens.
And they were able to do
so by really understanding
their end customers and
their shopping patterns
as well as understanding
developers, what they need,
and incentivizing them
to partner with them
and send them the right traffic.
The next thing I
want to talk about
is operational insights
and monitoring,
and this is actually used
by a lot of our customers
and a lot of
different verticals.
So I won't to give you a
particular customer's example.
But let me tell you about
the motivation, actually,
of why we created the
Monitoring module in Apigee.
Some of the largest retailers
in the US and across the globe,
actually, are
Apigee's customers.
And at critical
times of the year,
like the New Year's sale or the
Black Friday or Cyber Monday
sale, they experience
enormous amount of traffic.
So for example, in
2018, Black Friday,
we experienced close
to 110,000 transactions
per second sustained over
long durations of time.
And it's important that these
services for these customers--
they're up and running
without any disruption
because every
second of disruption
could cost them hundreds of
thousands, if not millions,
of dollars in revenue.
So Apigee has a really
robust API availability rate.
We surpass our SLAs.
But our customers
said that, hey,
sometimes there are
things on our end
that we need to troubleshoot.
Some of our services
get down for a variety
of different
reasons, and we would
love to get some
alerts for us to be
able to fix those
issues fast and get up
and running really fast.
So that was the motivation
behind Apigee Monitoring.
It addresses a particular
need for the operations teams.
And there's a lot of
pressure these days
for them to resolve issues very
fast, quickly diagnose issues,
and the data that
Apigee has, which
is specific to the
entities accessing the APIs
as well as services
that the API is tied to.
And the different
policies in your proxies
and where exactly that
error might be occurring
is very useful in diagnosing
these APIs issues.
So this is a diagram of how
Apigee monitoring differs
from just generic
synthetic monitoring.
The thing I want
you to focus on is
that the alerts that you get--
they are precise.
They tell you exactly where
the error has occurred.
They're contextual.
If the error is due
to a raised condition,
if it's intermittent,
it'll help you
zero-in on what exactly is
wrong and what is triggering
that particular error.
So just to sum it up,
Apigee Analytics actually
covers all of the personas
that need insights into the API
program to make it better.
It is your business
owner to get insights
on the strategy
for the API program
and how it's doing with
relation to the different KPIs
that the business team has set--
so the API team to monitor
the health of the API program
and figure out what
is gaining traction,
what needs more resources--
to the app developer to gain
insights into particular API
proxies and applications,
and to your ops teams
to get real-time
monitoring alerts
and help in
diagnosing the issues.
Let me jump right into a demo.
So this is how the
Apigee platform looks.
You have a place to
design your APIs.
create, build your APIs,
productize them, publish
them, and all of that,
and then you have a
place for analytics.
And to the left of the
screen, as you can see,
these are the out-of-the-box
dashboards that you have
to target specific personas
within your organization.
I would like to
begin with developers
because once you
have an API program,
usually the first
thing you think
about is, how are my
developers consuming
my APIs, what is my engagement
rate, and all of that?
So this dashboard will
give us just that.
So right now, as
you can see, there
is a funnel on the
screen, and you'll
be able to see how many
developers have signed up
for your API program and out of
the developers that have signed
up, how many have actually
created applications,
how many of those
applications are active,
and how many of those
applications are highly active.
And down below
you'll be able to see
how is each of the
application performing, what
is a traffic that
they are running
through their platform,
what is the error rate,
and all of that.
And then you can dig
in further to analyze
the high-level metrics.
The next thing that you
would be interested in just
for the high level is
a traffic composition.
Just tell me what are
the top 10 proxies that
are receiving the most traffic.
Tell me what are the
top applications that
are consuming my services, what
are the top 10 products that
are being accessed,
being consumed,
and who are the developers
that are the most active
on my platform?
So that is more a
high-level overview
of the health of
your API program.
If you're looking
at the end users,
if you're a product
manager, you would
want to gauge, where are
my end users located?
You'd be able to do that
with the GeoMap attribute
with Apigee.
Over here, as you
can see, I have
a lot of users coming
from the United States,
but also have global presence
in Australia, and Norway,
and China, Pakistan,
a lot of places.
So if I click on the
US, I'll be able to see
the different states where
traffic is coming from.
Most of it looks like it's
coming from California.
I can dig in deeper and see
what are different counties that
are sending me this traffic.
You can also see what
are the devices that are
accessing your applications.
So over here you can see that
the most popular platform looks
like it's Chrome, and Internet
Explorer, and so on and so
forth.
Most of the traffic
is coming from the PC,
and a lot of my users are
also using the smartphone,
mostly from Windows, also
from iOS and all of that.
So the next thing
I want to show you
is the API metrics
on a product level
as well as on an
API proxy level.
So if I click on the API Proxy
Performance, on this dashboard,
you'll be able to see what is
the health of all of my API
proxies.
For the traffic that you have
gotten, what of the successes,
and what are the errors?
You can see that my error
rate is pretty high, actually.
It's 8%.
So I need to make a
mental note that I
need to dig into what is
causing that error rate,
so we'll do that
in just a second.
You can also see that my average
response time for the proxy
is just a bit over
100 milliseconds.
For the target, it's a
bit over 250 milliseconds.
These are the traffic
patterns by proxy,
and there's the average response
time for each of the proxies.
In the same time, this
is for your proxies
that you are exposing on Apigee.
You can also get the
same kind of information
for your target back
ends that the proxies are
in turn hitting to get
the right data to execute
the right logic.
And you can see that
the traffic by target
tells you what the
traffic patterns are.
It also tells you that most
or all of it is successful.
Your back end is not showing
any errors, which is good.
Your response time,
averaged proxy is about 130.
Average target is close to 300.
And it also tells you a
bit about the payload.
You can also do latency
analysis, and cash performance,
and all of that.
Let me take a look at
error code analysis.
Let's see what kinds of
errors are we throwing.
So all of the errors
are proxy errors.
We knew that.
And a majority of those
errors are 400 errors,
4xx, mostly authentication,
and bad requests,
and all of that, which is good.
We want to deny those requests.
But a small percentage of
it is also 500, 5xx, errors.
We should look into that, what
exactly is going on there.
It also tells me what
is the error by proxy.
It looks like my
product search proxy
is receiving or generating
the most amount of errors--
so we'll take a look at that--
errors by target, and also
proxy errors by response code.
And most of the response code
is 401 or 500 and some 502s,
so we'll look into that as well.
Now let's dive right into some
of the business-level metrics.
So I mentioned that we
have a lot of customers
that are using these tools
to gain business level
insights on their revenues,
and on the marketing campaigns,
and all of that.
So let me show you
how you can do it.
So these are-- what I showed
you are out-of-the-box reports.
You have a lot of
metrics and data
available so that you can
create your own custom reports.
So let's say you are
a big-box retailer,
and you have a lot of retail
locations all across the globe.
For that, let's say I
want a revenue report
on how each one of my
locations are doing.
So I'll run this report
for the past hour,
as I just want it
to be real-time just
to monitor the health.
And it will tell me that, hey,
the majority or the highest
revenue grossing
store was my US 15
store, and my stores
in India, Norway,
Pakistan are doing pretty
well as well, as they
are in the top 10.
Let's say, on the
other hand, you
are running a
marketing organization,
and you want to see the health
of your marketing campaigns.
Then let's take a look
at the marketing report.
Let's run it for the past hour.
So over here you can see
that your traffic is divided
into three different blocks, and
one chunk is from social media.
So let's take a look in there.
As you can see, the
report is interactive.
It tells me that I have a few
different campaigns running.
One is a data privacy campaign.
There's also the money
back guarantee campaign,
all of that.
And it tells me what is
a traffic composition
from each one of
these, and it looks
like my expert conversation
campaign is grossing
the least amount of traffic.
So I hope that I'm also spending
the least amount of money
on that and the revenue per
dollar spent on that campaign
is worth my time.
So let's click on the
data privacy campaign
and look at what
kinds of channels
that the traffic is coming from.
It looks like most of
it is coming from blogs.
There's also some from Google,
LinkedIn, some influencer
marketing going on, and
the least amount of traffic
from Twitter and Instagram.
So it gives me a good
insight into what
is working for my campaigns
versus what is not working.
So now, lastly, what I want
to show you is API monitoring,
and the API monitoring
is about how
is the health of your
API program in real time.
So what you're seeing right
now is basically a dashboard.
It tells you what is the TPS
that your org is experiencing,
what is the error rate, what is
the latency, and all of that.
So one feature I want
to call out over here
is the alerting
feature, so over here
I've set a 500 error
alert to alert me
whenever my proxy surpasses a
threshold for the 500 errors.
In that threshold I've
set is that if there
is a constant rate of 3%
or higher for five minutes,
then please alert
me, and send me
an alert to this
particular email.
And you can choose
whatever mode you want,
integrated with
anything you want,
with webhook, or PagerDuty,
or Slack, or email.
So if I go to my
inbox, I was actually
getting some 500 alerts, and I
got a few alerts just recently.
So let me take a look at this
that I got about a day ago,
and it tells me that there's
a playbook for me to use
to troubleshoot that alert.
It also gives me the details
on exactly what that alert is.
So let me click on View
Details, so it will take me
to a report in the investigation
panel on API monitoring.
It tells me that, hey,
the status quo is 500,
and here was a spike
that I'm looking at.
It was constant, or
it was pretty stable
at that threshold for
about five minutes.
And that's how it got
triggered is right here.
It tells me that the
rate limit policy
that I have is
triggering this, so now I
have a pretty decent idea
of what exactly is going on.
I click on this.
It tells me that the
environment is production.
This is the proxy.
So if you recall from earlier,
the product search proxy
was also a proxy that was
throwing the most errors,
so I'm not surprised by this.
And it looks like a
lot of applications
are affected by this particular
error, so that's good to know.
And it also gives me some other
detail in terms of the message
processor and also the target
that my API proxy is calling
as part of these APIs calls.
And down below it tells
me that most of the errors
are generated from
the proxy itself,
and there are very few from the
target, so 3,500 from the proxy
itself.
So now I know
exactly where to go.
I know the particular
proxy that is impacted,
and I know the policy
within the proxy
that is throwing these errors.
So let me now go to Develop.
Let me click on API Proxies.
And now I'll go into the
Product-Search proxy,
and I'll go into Develop.
And this is the
SpikeArrest policy
that is throwing those errors.
It looks like I'm
saying that, hey,
if I receive more than
three requests per second,
then please throw errors.
Don't let them pass
through because I think
that is higher than I expect.
I think three
requests per second--
let's say I do some
analysis, I look
at the capacity and
back end systems,
and I feel like,
I could probably
increase it to seven requests
per second, and save it.
And now it's deployed,
and basically that's it.
Now I should expect
those error rates
to go down because my
SpikeArrest policy will
get triggered less often.
So this is basically what the
Apigee Analytics in monitoring
looks like.
So that's it for today.
Thank you for joining.
You can find more webinars
coming out every week,
so please tune-in for that.
And you can also find
recordings of our past webinars
on our YouTube channel.
Thanks again for joining.